I just did a webcast interview with some
folks in Australia and they were pushing
me very hard to try and explain how the
infinite mindset helps in times like
these and I had a thought on that call
that I wanted to share with everybody
which is these are not unprecedented
times there are many cases lists of
cases were change or something
unexpected has put many companies out of
business and made other companies come
out stronger and reinvent themselves the
invention of the internet put many many
companies out of business the ones who
could not reinvent their companies for
the Internet age but rather double down
on the old way they did business every
video story is out of business because
because of streaming and they couldn't
reinvent themselves when Starbucks moved
into neighborhoods many many companies
went out of business many coffee shops
went out of business
not because of Starbucks but because
they refused to change the way they did
business
they still had an old ripped up couch
when you had a better product uber is
putting taxi companies out of business
not because it Oberer it's because the
taxis refused to change this is not
unprecedented the fact that something
new and this more sudden absolutely more
shocking absolutely without a doubt but
this is not unprecedented in the
business world and so for us to say not
how do we do what we're doing but rather
how will we do what we're doing in a
different world and the world is
different
and and and and I and the thing that I
said on this interview was it's the
companies that have been investing in
will and had it and having an infant
infinite mindset for a long time that
will come out of this stronger because
they're prepared some of many of them
were saving money as opposed to giving
out huge fat bonuses to everybody and
spending all the money and the will of
the people is high to figure out a way
through it the ones that are struggling
the most are the ones that spend all
their money save nothing appeased Wall
Street and the will of the people is low
that people are in survival mode rather
than reinvention mode
it's the companies that with an infinite
mindset that are and reinvention mode
it's the companies with the finite
mindset that are in survival mode
regardless of how much money they have
it's the mindset how are we gonna get
through this versus how are we gonna
change to get through this
so I feel so optimistic because we're
thinking about the future we're in a
dark tunnel but there's a light over
there I don't know how far away that
light is but I can see it but we're in
darkness now but when we come out of
there we will have a better train a
different train we will be a completely
different business some of us will have
different jobs by the time we get out of
this and that's our opportunity the
opportunity is what will we be not how
do we to preserve what we had that's an
infinite mindset and I'm so proud of
this team because my attitude is this
not theoretically but because I'm
watching a team go through it right now
and watching people reinvent themselves
I'm watching people think about their
jobs differently I'm watching people
think how can I contribute in a new way
I'm watching people say what could we be
how will we bring our message to people
in a different way and new ways that
will last forever by the way not just
for now so proud of you guys love you
guys
because we are a living example of the
stuff that I'm talking about out loud I
get to say we are doing this
we're not allowing uber to put us out of
business we're not online Starbucks to
put us out of business
we're not allowing the internet to put
us out of business
we'll reinvent ourselves this is not
unprecedented this has happened many
many many times in business this was
just a little more sudden
different jobs you don't mean different
jobs out of this company but reinvent
yourself within this company that is the
opportunity so I know a company it's a
hot fine-dining restaurant in New York
City he's figured out a way to become a
delivery company all of his people have
kept their jobs because they have
different jobs now but if you think
you're gonna do the same job and you're
waiting like if you're a public speaker
who was waiting for this to get through
so you can go stand on a stage I got
some bad news
that that ship has sailed we have to be
a normal company now we have to market
ourselves and and develop product
this is a huge wake-up call for us we
have week we had the luxury of being
lazy and I don't mean that in a bad way
there was no reason to reinvent when
when we're drinking from a firehose
but now the opportunity is magical I'm
thinking how do I put myself out there
without a stage this is entirely new for
me as well
this is entirely new for me
but I'm not worried about what I do I'm
worried about why I do it and I will
find a job that helps me do that
a make a job that helps me do that
and expect the same of everyone and
here's the best thing you don't have to
do it alone we've got each other's backs
we'll help each other some of it will be
easy some of it will be unbelievably
difficult
this is a very very magical team we're
streamlined
good all right I got to go the doctor
Thank You Simon all right I love you
guys
wash your hands more I'm more worried
about the doctor bye
[Music]
you